I'm only talking to the people that are
ready to get to the next level of they
life and they career and they're going
to boldly walk
until the next season of their life.
Unapologetically getting rid of all
things people in situations that no
longer belong in their life.
Most of you,
most of you,
you're so consumed
with everything that's going on in the
world.
This is the reasons you haven't figured
out your own life yet.
Every blog,
every website,
every tweet,
every instagram post,
you are so consumed with everything
that's going on in the world.
You're ignoring your own world.
You can never shine trying to sit on
someone else's son.
You can never figure out who you are if
you consumed and everything that
everybody else is and what they're doing
in the moves that they're making because
you're trying to chase someone else's
life.
You're trying to chase someone else's
lifestyle and identity all while
ignoring your own life and your own
path.
What is the vision for your life?
What are the ideas and the dreams for
your life?
What are you supposed to be doing?
Who are you?
What are your gifts and talents?
What is your ultimate destiny and your
goals
and you should understand this,
that it was always going to be your
family and your friends.
That would be the first ones to try and
talk you out of your vision and your big
idea.
That's why you supposed to live your
life,
focus on your intentions and do your
thing.
Did you allow yourself worth to be based
on what other people think of you?
Is the beginning of the end.
I believe in me.
If you stop believing in me,
I'm not going to believe in myself any
less.
If you believe that I'm irrelevant,
that no one is checking for me and that
I don't mean anything to the world
because you think or believe that about
me,
it doesn't mean that I'm going to
believe it about myself.
See,
the day that you start living your life
according to everybody else's opinion is
the beginning of the hand.
Most of you guys don't actually know
yourself or you don't know yourself.
Value.
Believe in yourself.
Believe in yourself independent of the
validation of the world.
Have opinions and feelings about
yourself,
independent of the feedback.
I really think,
and if you get rid of the trash in your
life,
that can be people,
business in situations you too couldn't
really like.
I really believe that you can reach your
full potential.
I want you
to fly.
I want you and your career and your
financial blessings to bypass me.